show comparables if you're trying to
raise money off an idea that other
people have done before you're trying to
buy into a current system show
comparables so it makes the decision
easier for an investor to say yes one of
the hardest things for the investors to
say yes to is risk right if you are the
first person to try to do something
there's a lot of risk attached to it and
so there might be a lot of opportunity
but then there's a lot of risk and so
it's hard for them to say yes but if you
can show them that this has been done
before and the kind of numbers that it
generates then it's easier for them to
say yes because they have a clear
understanding of the opportunity and
they know what the risk level is so
reduce their risk by showing comparables
I got a question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys Joe Cocker and Joe
Cocker is trying to raise money he wants
to start a kiosk in a mall around the
Tommie copper product I've never heard
of Tommy copper but that's cool so to
get this thing going you want to raise
this money you want to quit this
business plan show me some comparables
show me who else has done a Tommie
copper kiosk how much money they're
making how much their costs are and how
their location is relevant to mine
that's what an investor is gonna look at
it's gonna be a pretty simple
calculation okay that other kiosk how
much is it making how much are they
spending and how does the mall that
they're when compared to the mall that
you want to go to if those numbers work
out it's easy to say yes if they don't
work out then it's gonna be a lot harder
to raise the money this might even be
something that the banks would look at
depending on how your relationship is
with your bank manager if I was
financing this it depends on the
investor going after this is not a
venture capital type of investment this
is more an angel investor but not even a
strategic angel investor it's just
somebody to give you money and this
could be in the form of a loan if you
want something to being like the ten to
fifteen percent interest rate they give
you the money and you create your
location and go from there if you can
get a strategic angel investor
and put some experience to help you grow
this thing to multiple locations that's
a bonus but I I think you're looking at
just a guy with money you're looking at
like a dentist a doctor a lawyer who
wants a hands-off investment where they
can get a premium return on on a loan
that they're giving you it's probably
your best bet and for them to say yes
show them comparables of people who've
done it before believe for those you're
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below let me know you think leave a
comment you have a question put it in
the comment section below and if you
like this video if you want to see more
you can subscribe to the channel and see
what else I'm up to thank you so much
and I'll see you soon